I want a game out with you guys, the various
possible outcomes for the 2020 election, but
I admit I'm sort of scared to do this on the
show because there will be people in the audience
who will misunderstand what I'm doing either
deliberately or they will just misunderstand
it.
There will be people in the audience who think
that I am in this segment going to suggest
we support someone other than a real progressive
in 2020 and I want to be clear, I'm doing
this segment because this is what we do on
the show.
This is the type of thing that over the years
people have come to appreciate about the show.
We think about things, we consider possibilities,
we discuss them, but let me put this in front
of everything so that I am not misunderstood.
We should vote for the person whose values
and policies most closely match ours and I
am a progressive, so I believe we should vote
for a progressive.
Now, that being said, that disclaimer, given
I want to game out 2020 with you.
Let's imagine for basic scenarios for 2020
think about it like a two by two grid.
On one side, there's the possibility that
Democrats nominate either a centrist or a
progressive.
For this example, we could say Biden or Bernie,
you could say Klobuchar or Warren.
If you want to go by the New York times endorsements,
whatever the Democrats could nominate a centrist
or a progressive along the other axis is the
possibility that Donald Trump either wins
reelection or loses it.
This gives us four possible outcomes.
You could nominate a progressive and see them
lose to Trump, or you could nominate a progressive
and see them defeat Trump and become president.
You could also see a centrist nominated and
lose to Donald Trump, or you can see a Centrus
nominated and defeat Donald Trump.
I want to explore with you whether the best
outcome for the longterm for Progressive's
might be that a centrist like Joe Biden be
nominated but lose to Donald Trump in 2020
I've read some articles about this over the
last few months and I want to think through
the scenarios with you.
Let's first imagine that a is nominated but
loses to Trump in November.
This is bad for the progressive movement because
it will be used not only by the right, but
it'll even be used by the centrists left to
say, look, you got a shot.
You nominated a progressive and they lost.
This proves we can't move the party to the
left centrism and moderation and trying to
compromise with crazy Republicans is the path
forward and that could damage the left for
a long time to come.
Next scenario would be that a progressive
is nominated and wins defeats Donald Trump
in 2020 in this case, that progressive would
have to govern with a likely Republican Senate
for at least two years, if not more, and the
serious possibility of losing control of the
house in the midterms.
As often happens when you have a party change
in a presidential election, the next midterm,
the party that takes control in the presidential
loses control of the house.
Now none of that's guaranteed, but particularly
with the Republican Senate, and especially
if Democrats lose control of the house in
2022 this would be a progressive president
who will undoubtedly fail to accomplish many
of their major campaign promises and it would
also be called a major defeat for the progressive
left.
Look, you got someone in there and they didn't
do a damn thing.
Republicans will take advantage.
Centrist Democrats will say, look, you won
and you couldn't do anything in 2022 and in
2024 and beyond.
There are counter arguments and we'll get
to them later.
We're being thorough here.
Next possibility.
A centrist like Joe Biden wins the nomination
and defeats Trump in 2020 now to a lot of
us, this feels very unlikely, myself included,
but let's imagine that Biden is nominated
and wins.
This is of course terrible for the progressive
movement because Joe Biden's not a progressive.
This would allow the centrist Democrats to
claim the way to fight the right is with a
moderate like Joe Biden.
They'll say, look, we nominated a centrist
and a centrist one.
They will say, that's evidence that progressivism
is not the way to go.
Now, Biden of course won't do anything hugely
progressive because he's not a progressive
and the center left will say, this is the
way to go.
This is how you win with a centrist Democrat.
That could also damage the progressive movement
for a long time.
So then we get to scenario number four, which
again, is this the best game theory outcome,
which is that a Biden or another centrist
is nominated, but they lose to Donald Trump
in November of 2020 in the long term, this
might be the best for the progressive movement.
Number one, it would continue to provide support
for the idea that the way to beat the right
is not with a centrist because you'll have
Hillary having lost to Trump and Biden having
lost to Trump.
That's a real strong case that it's really
time for a progressive.
A centrist would have been nominated and lost
again.
We would also get another four years of an
even more unhinged and erratic Trump who no
longer has to run for reelection, who would
likely be even crazier than the Trump of the
first term, and this might further justify
supporting a true progressive as the obvious
and only way to go in 2024 now, of course,
that would be a pretty bad four years for
the United States of America.
So I'm not here to suggest we elect Joe Biden.
I'm not voting for Joe Biden in the primary.
I'm not here to suggest we allow Donald Trump
to win in 2020 what I'm presenting to you
from a game theory perspective is the possibility
that over the long term, the progressive left
might benefit from Biden being the nominee
and losing to Trump despite it being an absolutely
horrible outcome for the country in the immediate.
Now there are many counter arguments to be
made.
Let's make some of them.
One is a progressive president elected in
2020 wouldn't lose the house in 2022 uh, nor
would they suffer from a Republican Senate
the entire presidency.
They might not get it in 2020 but they could
likely get it in 2022 and then they could
actually get some things done.
They could put in place some of the most significant
progressive change in history.
That's a possibility.
That would be a counter argument that one
could make.
It would require a reversal from historic
trends, but it is a completely valid counter
argument to what I'm suggesting.
Another counter argument would be there are
people who feel super strongly that Bernie
and Warren simply would not lose to Trump,
and that they would get a lot done.
Let me know what you think.
Game it out with me.
And again, we're, we're talking like adults
here.
I'm voting for a progressive and I'm voting
to defeat Donald Trump.
This is a conversation that I'm having with
you about the four possible outcomes.